okay I'm live trying to overcome some of
the technical hurdles which I think I've
managed to do I'm streaming from a hot
spot me shift the board over a little
bit and I was having audio issues with
some testing but now it should be okay
okay so we're playing Jesse's let's play
and I have six and I forgot to mention
we're playing the winter marathon
tournaments one of Li chesses notorious
24 hour long very brutal blitz
tournaments I just joined this is my
first game I'm in six thousand five
hundred and sixty eighth place I know if
I said that correctly but h3h3 not
supposed to be good can i play queen h5
or Queen h4 Queen h4 runs into g3 I take
on f2 okay let's just take here
I've seen some trap before okay I don't
have time to talk about it though let's
just continue developing nights before
bishops I'll probably put the Bishop on
c5 or b4 probably be for slightly more
aggressive in many cases the queen will
come to e7 and then now I'm hoping that
he plays on g3 so I can maybe be
possibly made on f3 so Knight still
controls f3 maybe g5 let's play g5 looks
like a fun move there is a line in the
Budapest
if Y plays an early Bishop f4 them that
can play an early g5 g4 looks like an
option trying to justify g5 let's take I
just want to create weaknesses and then
induce a blunder that's the main plan
hey it's a Saab Sansa Knights
thanks for the sub and there's people in
the chat hello people in the chat
Samsonite I thought of you today because
I was at the airport's and the person in
front of me was carrying a bag that said
Samsonite's cuz I think it's a brand of
like luggage or backpacks or something
I think I'm winning material this is
actually a really nice tactic if he
takes with Queen I fork if he takes with
pawn it's double checkmates on f3 but
okay I'll win the Queen
probably should have desert to this game
but that's okay
gives me more time to relax and drink
water was the last time I drank water on
stream I usually drink tea let's play
Bishop f5 I'll queenside castle and then
try and somehow mates along the e-file
at d4 oh this is made into that's nice
okay back to tournament and hello to
more people
Belgium novice no fortnight please well
that's an easy wish to fulfill many
names I can't pronounce the doctor hello
PD bull talk with a sub thanks for the
sub PD bull talk four months in a row Oh
Samson light was also four months in a
row okay we're gonna play another black
opening another budapest boo the pastas
are great opening for blitz lots of
traps III is playable
I don't want to transpose into some like
French defense I'll play C 6 and then D
5 there's a little bit of lag having
some issues drawing arrows but I like
this position your pawn on e4 will be
well reinforced the ship will come to f5
usually the Queen comes e7 and life is
good
he wants to play Knight g3 so let's try
and discourage that now if he plays my
g3 I drop the bishop back and play h4
here I can play Queen e7 defending both
pawns
I'm just waiting for him to castle so I
can carry through with the attack
is b5 chaplet bishop looks like a bishop
trap like his knight and his queen
developed two squares which just
obstruct the bishop and now I'm up a
bishop or up at night and life is better
all Castle next and I'll use open vials
how did I get so good am I really that
good it's a lot of people on this planet
better than me um no I I mean I got or I
improved too chess by playing since I
was 7 years old I've been playing chess
for what's the year it's 2018 I've been
playing since 2002 so it helps to have
like a lot of experience under your
belts and especially with new players
who are looking to improve patience is
very key
sometimes a main factor which separates
players from the next level is just
experience okay i'll beserk this game
I'll play E for my first white game and
let's play let's play something
aggressive I'm gonna play something I
used to play in childhood some version
of the Italian there should be seven a
bit less common more people will play
Bishop c5 or Knight f6 so okay I'm just
gonna develop
put the bishop on g5
and I would like to get some sharp
position I already forgot I desert so I
have to also watch out for time also
watch out for this pawn on d4 let's move
the bishop back I'm completely okay with
double pawns
please take on f3 hey grunt bug ly with
a sub thanks grunt ugly
yeah the thing about double pawns in a
position like this is okay because I'm
not castled and I want a castle Queen
side taking a lot three wouldn't only
help me open the G file but okay it's
not happening but still a pleasant
position this bishops not doing much on
g4 I'll probably play f3 and pawn storm
relatively soon I want to trade let's do
it
three
now I'll probably Castle kingside I
don't care about the b2 pond because if
Queen takes B - there's rook e1 and I
win stuff it's liking each one I might
still go for this bond storm Queen James
B 2 or P 1 Queen a3 York takes b7 ooh
d5 not a bad move ok stuff is being
traded
takes with Brooke digging with rook
keeps initiative but the pawn on e6 is
weak
c3 defends us now black has a little
more activity like the rooks are better
placed but White has a better structure
my time situations not so great okay 32
seconds it's a decent amount of time oh
but I beserk so there's no increments I
kind of forgot about that okay so off to
win over the board I just want to put
them okay let's put play this oh no I
hung the bishop no so now I have a bad
position and okay nevermind could have
been really bad if you played Queen
takes off for blind spot for both of us
so now the only thing that's bad is a
time situation but everything else is
reasonable isn't it trade rooks probably
picking on each two actually
computing the facts
and now I want to put the rock on g4
maybe play c4 first
actually no I like the pawn on c3
prevents rip t4 let's play h5
hmmm I can put the rockin g6
and maybe went up on there we go 18
seconds still a decent amount of time
18 seconds is at least like 30 moves
now I want to play h6 and just crash
through and he's getting him a long time
but he has increments weird situation
queen g4 is also an idea targeting a six
actually maybe off like queen g4 firsts
is oh I could take on e6 immediately
yeah it's just about playing quickly now
when the queen keep checking with the
pawn
he's not gonna flag though because he
has increments uh he gave me a rook
let's take this rook
he didn't under twice okay so I'll
promote the pawn okay now he gave me the
mic now I can pre move give you the rest
of the game
Wow there's lag though okay two more
moves until mates there we go
somewhat of a close finish but finished
nonetheless this is slightly stressful
hello to more people in the chat Alex
Tsar azzam GM I'm doing I'm doing
decently and it's bits it's 600 no it's
five hundred it's from grunt buggy
things from bubbly
let's not buzzer again that's too
stressful and you got Jess with two
hundred bits and so many bits thanks
guys for the generosity so I'm playing
some version of the like caro-kann panel
attack regards from Mexico oh lava boy
knows the points yes or buenos noches
don't know what time it is and Mexico
probably boy honest yes
okay so let's develop he's already
played a little bit like inaccurately by
taking on d5 with the Queen usually
black should played out of six and take
on d5 with the Knights so I'm just gonna
develop and be normal castle it'd be
nice if I can prevent black from
castling like maybe t5 soon open the
center or Bishop b5 check Lithuania
Scottish Highlands such a diverse group
of viewers let me know like what
countries are represented in the chats
anyone from like Asia or North America
because I'm streaming a kind of a weird
time let's play a this move UK Malaysia
Sweden Netherlands Canada Australia one
person from the USA that's nice this
chat is insane like within five seconds
there's got to be at least like fifteen
to twenty different responses okay so I
got D five and I'm taking on e6 I'm
looking through the chat no one in the
chat has mentioned the country that I
mean currently in hey one person it's
from the country that I'm currently in I
can't pronounce your name Hazen's
I just arrived in Indonesia today I was
here last year it's a nice country
traffic was pretty clear at least at
nighttime okay so I can take the bishop
I can take the pawn I can apply more
pressure what to do queen bee 3 is a
move there's so many good-looking moves
here Queen f3 is a move
let's play Queen three
because the bishop is attacked twice the
pawns attacks and not defended he six
plans gonna hang at some points you're
terrified of snakes - terrified of
snakes - ever go to Indonesia I didn't
know snakes are a thing in Indonesia
I've haven't seen a snake here yet let's
take on b7 now that rooks attacked pawn
is still easy to take I think I'll take
with Bishop keep my knight because the
knight is effective on e6 targets of
rook targets of G pawn
expecting rookie aid or opiates South
Africa is a country I want to go to but
it's far away I cou started watching on
YouTube
wait the comment just disappeared ah
nice there's a lot of people who will
watch on YouTube check my twitch stream
and then just be surprised when I'm live
and streaming I'm hoping to stream more
consistently like at least in the new
year I know this last month has been a
bit hectic but that's a matter of
finding a routine and there's been so
much love recently from like twitch and
YouTube that want to keep providing some
song value can playing somewhat of a
defensive move but the point is to get
this rook into the game please connect
the rooks
making a simple threats hoping he
doesn't see it even if he does see it
what does black do here maybe you're up
G it's g 6 g 6 makes my bishop happy
because now dark squares are easier to
exploit
in Queen f4 is a idea maybe Queen h4 and
then Queen b6 and then Queen g7
I'm only up upon but the positions good
going for the kill
you ever of g8 good move
looking for an instant kill here I'm
gonna play what I think is objectively
the best move the backward attacking of
obscuring the Queen and rook just pick
up material even though I really want to
keep my Bishop rook as a rook and I'll
still go for mates you're threatening
made in one black is low on time I'll
get the rooks into play
I want to smother mate so bad let's keep
the Queen's on the board I think I'll go
for like oh he just flags I'm gonna say
I was gonna go for Queen b3 unite of
seven but that words
okay so I've gained zero rating points
so far on the verge of breaking into the
top 3000 there's a lot of people
planning this tournaments by close to
10,000 for the people who want to play
me you can join this tournament and have
a very slim chance of getting paired
against me
let's beserk and let's play this move
I'm gonna play a Petrov
okay now we have a four Knights will
just continue to copy him
easy play D 386 get ready to castle
Bishop d2 I don't want to copy bishop
doesn't belong on d2
I was playing in a slightly unusual
fashion like a 3 B 4 and Bishop d2 are
not moves that are normally played at
least at the high level in this opening
I'm liking the position I think
structures nice as bishops powerful this
bishops affected there's a few plans
here one plan is to bring the knight to
d4 the other plan is to play at five and
then storms on how the other plan is to
do this and then Knight f5 and target
some weaknesses whoa this is getting
messy takes Queen e2
I might be losing material ooh I got
careless think I got careless
let's play efore and try and confuse
them
I forgot I was er 37 seconds left
okay so at least we're training and now
I'll play this and then I don't have
rook e8 immediately but I have c6 if he
takes threatening the bishop and
threatening rookie AIDS queen f2 strange
move still going for c6 which was
probably just illogical let's play Queen
e7 the king is stuck in the center you
can pre move this my Knights stuck let's
play six
this is really bad I have 17 seconds
left and I'm losing a piece if he plays
rook e1 or am i queen bee - it's a
miracle a belated Christmas miracle wait
I'm winning everything
like he has to play King g1 that's only
legal move then I take the rook and then
I win the Queen Queen c1 I just take
here this is so beautiful so now the
goal is just not to flag and play this
move
pre-move that I pre moved it because if
he Queens of what P illegal going for
the kill
mmm queen up for his mates yeah
depending where he goes
some close calls
this weekend's slightly stressful not
the cleanest situation that happened got
very messy the okay night at five was
not the safest move to play I just
assumed that okay something should work
here but it's a bit tricky if I play
Knight g3 there's Rick g1 and then I
mean II for you can just take on you for
and I think I was gonna go for like some
Queen f6 or something I take C 3 and
then Queen f6 anyway okay it's still
perfect gains our rating points worked
hard for that rating points let's go
back I cannot play this whole tournament
and I'm using a whole lot of data on
this hot spots so this next game might
be in one of my last games so we'll see
I always freak that I deserve that's
true short-term memory loss okay we're
playing this guy that's not loser that
way I I physically can't forget that I
deserved just don't preserve and I'm
gonna play another Buddha past it's been
serving me well so far
and t5 so this is a couple people
already avoiding the Budapest it's not
the best gambit to decline the black is
just happy and Bishop g5 is a blunder
because I can take and if King takes I
play Knight g4 classic trap up upon nice
position white can't castle now
let's stay aggressive going for a night
f2 or queen f2
queen up to candy 193 king c1 I don't
really want to trade Queens
so let's not I'm gonna actually let's
trade Queens because I don't think that
line led to anything there's nowhere
else great for the Queen to go but if he
takes on you three my knight comes in
it'll be threatening Knight c2 and then
my Knights can start talking to each
other three it's mildly annoying I could
just take in retreats if I'd check
problem is Queen off to King G 193 king
c1 might be 494 my queen gets trapped
oh wait no I'm winning c4 though yeah
let's go for this forgot I'm winning c4
probably could have gone for that
earlier
not used to the c4 pawn being undefended
and then okay my Knights can coordinate
or I'll play Queen III next enforcer
Queen trade
and I'm managing my time for puns from
South Korea look who's not too many
viewers from South Korea thanks for the
comments I could have taken the bishop I
didn't see the bishop was hanging it's
just a blind spot it's usually like the
opponent's pieces on the on their like
back rank are defended enough times okay
so my Knights attacked I could move back
let's just trade Queens no I wanted to
play Queen III queen a queen takes you
to he's probably so confused now that's
an obvious math slip but I'm not gonna
cry too much cuz now it's just more of a
challenge this is actually gonna be
challenging because there's increments
so I can't really dirty flag him least I
still have my Knights
let's move the bishop to f5
it would be great if he plays rip t1 the
worst possible move in the position
please favorite even your pawn needs
defending
kintel by like the way he's not moving
here that he's a little bit nervous I
wonder if he's watching trying to get
some some insights do my queenside
castle give away the pawn no I'm gonna
sack the pawn on a king side castle
daring him to take the pawn if my take
c7 I get some meaning attack along the C
file I should have taken on d5 though
that's okay or is it okay
is what to do
maybe Brooke c8 and then I'll play c6
just open the file get to the king he
played rugby one night b3 his mates
that's so nice it's such a great mating
pattern just just a bishop in the night
doing work I think that's a nice way to
end it did I like predictor of d1 a few
moves ago natural looking move
No the funny thing is if I play Queen
III I probably would not have won so
quickly it would have been harder to
checkmate so that actually worked out
quite well he let his guard down pretty
bad game but okay that was entertaining
so yeah I think I'm gonna end it there
I appreciate the viewership and the
diversity and the chats it's interesting
time to stream where like it seems like
a lot of different people and different
regions are awake a lot of new names too
orna car 2 is or no car to who I think
it is or maybe he's a second or a car
anyway um I'm gonna take off because I
don't know use up all my data my first
day like after just getting a SIM card
so so yeah I'm gonna try and stream one
more time in 2018 and then stay tuned
for more content in 2019 see you guys in
the future